lots en semaine c'est pourquoi on est en
live
je suis en train de vérifier il ya zéro
et mieux vaut mieux qu'on met du coup
comme ça un symbole de l est ce qu il en
faut deux bourses wall une personne je
ne sais pas et à une personne
yacine patronat a donc donc dans son
mandat effectivement impossible en live
je vais les fils un peu partout je suis
en live sur facebook
c'est ainsi que youtube a donnée à
l'éducation aux gens parce que donc le
live et blanches et de surchauffe big
sûr twitch je le vois pas je sais pas si
quelqu'un peut y voir la logique et les
rouages du pouvoir avoir les
commentaires des gens depuis twitch ceci
n'est pas un chat on est en live on est
en psychiatrie
bonjour à tous mais il fallait un peu le
temps de bons jours parce qu'on n'a
jamais moore qui nous permet d'avoir des
gens avec nous d'ailleurs plusieurs
écrans et on a cliqué en galère va
peut-être que je vais vous vous laisser
dire bonjour juste le temps de régler le
problème de clinique et peut-être
honteux sommes ici pour parler de taille
noir corbeau ou quand vous débarquez
déjà et puis il faut d'abord vous
laisser vous présenter ces pratiques
olala qu'on propose c'est pas la mère de
laurence c'est pas la réal était occupé
avec avec l'onu adacore en plus quand
rémy arrivera faudra casse pas en direct
parce que c'est que le mythe s'est
avérée non mais oui c'est vrai tu es pas
du coup je m'appelle florence à ce qui
est mon problème actuel finalement
ce que je peux dire que j'étais dans la
belle puisque on fait parler parce que
je viens en premier dans l'ordre
alphabétique à mon problème actuel c'est
super pourquoi je suis une robe grande
oratrice
j'essaie dans la saison 1 de time warp
j'étais bourré avec de la cire un moment
donné on est à revoir puisque je jouais
là pirates et la cyber historienne qui a
un prénom maintenant puisqu'elle
s'appelle havas
ce qui si on prenait les ordre
alphabétique serait également un
problème et pour les deux cas tu es
foutu la santé astrid à main oui c'est
vrai et est quelqu'un d'autre peut-être
voilà ce que j'ai fini de me présenter
ou où les huninguois plus que fais tu
dans la vie oui voilà bah du coup je
suis notre islam comédienne et parfois
je suis photographe et moi d'aller
j'ai déjà été assistante real mais là je
ne le suis pas voilà je fais beaucoup de
choses
bonjour se connaître voilà sinon je
connais justin parce qu'avant la bise et
dans le nord oui et qu'on faisait du
postes-clés même si on se feront se
fréquentaient pas tant que ça à l'époque
on faisait du cosplay mais on
connaissait très dense de l'une et de
l'autre
c'est vrai je me rappelle de ce poste
sur quatre forum.com où tu expliquer
l'origine de ton pseudo et rip petit
enfant peut nourrir l'espoir était autre
chose qui existe encore remy et là
incroyable sera dite par les états unis
bonsoir bonsoir que alors oui en tentant
jeu par le comité un petit peu vas-y et
repart pour voir où est quelqu'un qui
parle un bientôt à ce que ça veut dire
problème
ah ah non c'est pas du tout depuis le
téléphone du coup du coup on était en
train de se présenter devant des pâtes
imposait de te présenter director que tu
viens d'arriver sociaux et sauf si t'es
lancé que tu veux y aller au tour de me
remet bonjour moi c'est guillaume j'ai
joué thierry de la cyber histoire dans
la première phase ou qu'ils aient un
rôle sûrement le rôle le plus important
on va pas se mentir c'est très très
drôle a joué j'ai très hâte de le
reprendre ce rôle pour la deuxième
saison
parce que va se passer beaucoup de
choses savait très cool sinon dans l' aj
je suis dans le domaine de l'histoire de
l'art j'avais une chaîne youtube fait
entendre mais qu'il est aujourd'hui et
de son activité mais mais voilà on a un
petit soit en arrière-plan je sais pas
si c'est quelqu'un qui a une telle
je crois qu'on a trouvé le problème
donc voila vous étiez entrée entendra
youtuber pokémon parler en anglais de ne
sais pas quoi intéressant on va
continuer la présentation en bas du coup
c'est mon tour je crois en bougies
vendues qu'on va garder le tempo bah du
coup moi je suis juste ile de france je
suis au sida prof sur youtube et sur
twitter et sur facebook je sais que vous
menez actuellement
donc je suis vulgarisatrice en histoire
sur youtube et je réalise aussi time
warp qui est une web série dont la
saison a déjà été diffusé donc si nous
ne la connaissais pas je vous invite à
aller la regarder et donc si on est
réuni ce soir c'est pour vous parler de
la saison 2
qu'on est en train de quand on vient de
lancer la campagne de financement dont
justement on va en faire un petit tour
de présentation on va vous parler de la
série en elle-même
2 pourquoi cette campagne si vous avez
des questions j'avais tu m'avais déjà
une
on y répondra avec plaisir voilà au mois
et c'est alors maintenant c'est à moi
donc moi celle où j'étais attention
quand tu as dit je suis mauvais élève
j'écrivais des messages en même temps à
des gens dont on vient de lancer la
campagne de financement dont vous
arrêtez moi on entendait en double parce
que j'étais enfin de partager sur
facebook lite
sabotage là non donc du coup tout marche
oui ça fonctionne qu'est ce que je
disais oui ici alors attendre c est quoi
c'était quoi ces coûts je fatigue et
donc moi celle où et sur ce projet alors
là pour la saison un gta attend que je
dise bien tout real chef op cadreuse
monteuse a les traits des effets
spéciaux et là je serai juste chez ford
pour cette saison de voila je viens peut
enlever les cats iv qui avait trop
tarder avoir plus de tête pour les pour
mettre le cap ouest voilà parce que
c'était un petit peu compliqué et du
coup pour cette saison 2 aura essayé de
la faire les choses plus simplement et
je serai seulement lâché faute mais ses
capés htc est capable d'ailleurs on
pourrait te montrer dans quoi on parle
et on a des beaux lieux oui mais
françois therrien et bien je m'appelle
en soi et je survive pour la saison 2
qui n'était pas là à la saison une donc
je suis une des nouvelles casquettes
justement ou du coup j'arrive en tant
que qu'assistant réalisateur
il est donc j'ai déjà eu l'occasion du
coup de travailler un peu sur la saison
2 la faire des petits documents des
petites listes de tout est fait comme ça
et et voilà elle plus
[Musique]
ces présents lors du tournage justement
ne sera pas toujours d'esprit pour être
la caméra comme elle passera du temps de
jeu ça passe vingt quatre heures ça ce
sera encore une autre personne qui est
pas là ce soir mais pour diriger une
bonne équipe en d1 c'est un qui dit
l'alphabet s'est fait à moi rhdp
complètement ji yai aller au khimki a
posé une question de l'ordre
il ya deux questions va laisser que les
miss présentes et puis on répondra déjà
ou de questions mais compte déjà sali
voilà ta pas des compteurs je suppose
quelque chose on a mis fin à écouteur
micro qui permettrait que ça marche
mieux
alors que l'aînée du lipsync et clemi
clemi jouer donc lucrecia dans la saison
une et donc sera de nouveau présente
dans la saison 2 a enfin pu lucrecia et
peut-être trente ans qu'un autre
personnage tintin et voilà des poussines
ont clemi et comédienne à ses heures et
puis et puis cosplayeuses aussi voilà
pourquoi et votre et on avait déjà des
questions
j'aimerais savoir comment on vit dans le
turf ulissi s'entend avec ou sans
masquer quelques mois en france merci va
avoir la soudure et sans relief du
pailhasse répondre vous n'avez pas accès
en fait à cette information puisque vous
êtes des personnes du 21e siècle et que
donc pour éviter tout le paradoxe
temporel
je ne peux pas vous donner des détails
sur sur notre époque je suis désolé que
ce que ce que thierry aurait très bien
pu dire lui a d'ailleurs
cet épisode ailleurs que dans la saison
une on voulait pas qu'on voit des
fenêtres et où quand on arrive dans le
futur je voulais quelque chose de très
neutre et parce que justement les east
side à l'historien qui font venir des
personnes du passé chez eux ils veulent
pas que les personnes du passé récupère
peut-être une quelconque information
pour ça aussi qu'ils avaient des vieux
ordinateurs et pas des ordinateurs
futuriste et pas du tout parce qu'on
n'avait pas du tout terrier complet pour
coller au cul les questions c'était
qu'est ce qui se passe si la prof
rencontre son ancêtre et l'oxi
accidentellement
eh bien ce n'est pas grave il ya une
explication très logique
en gros qu'on a pour justifier que le
cyber historiens justement tuer leurs
ancêtres puisque a pas aussi tu es ma
descendance donc techniquement situer un
peu tes ancêtres c'est que quand ils
sont pas à leur période et qu'on les
tuent
il ya un double qui apparaît à la bonne
période et qui prend le relais et qui
n'a aucune connaissance aucun souvenir
du fait qu'il est allé dans le futur ça
c'est juste ce giro pop et puis il
reprend de là où il s'était arrêté quoi
c'est explicable scientifiquement et est
donc c'est l'astuce qu'on avait inventé
bah c'est forcément les histoires sur
les voyages d'antan j'essayais d'être
groupement pressenti fixe et pas trop
possible et je suis d'accord avec ce que
dit black semble que le voyage dans le
futur est effectivement possible mais on
pouvait y revenir c'est le temps qui
passe est bon ou pas bon je suis désolé
peut-être vous avez des trucs mais je
voulais faire cette blague à assumer
cette blague
il est 21 ans 12 as à me montrer
différents jeux justement il ya
quelqu'un qui te demande de black swan
qui demande pour le nouveau scénario est
ce que vous avez potasser les paradoxes
temporels
tu as ta réponse non on en crée de
nouveaux éventuellement le permettait
pas de paradoxe occuper ce rôle
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui fait la
saveur des films sur lauriad dans le
tarn alcoolo mais public trop où
exactement il les traque les loups
parler ou lupo là moi je trouve que
c'est ce qui fait la beauté de ce long
vraiment ça prouve à quel point le final
le film de marc les leurs mais comment
est ce qu'on peut faire pour prouver aux
scénaristes qu'ils ont eu tort aux qui
se sont plantés je voulais moi je pose
c'est beau quelque part c'est certain
mais c'est vrai au final qu'est ce qui
est mieux un film sur voyages d'antan
qui veut soi disant faire totalement
scientifique mais qui se plantent
forcément ou un film sans une série
survive j'entends majeur dr ou qu'ils
sont fous qui de temps en temps dit un
oui mais ça à mon en fait c'est pas
possible et finalement c'est possible
dans cet épisode plus loin joker géant
temps qu'une nouvelle règle finalement
est-ce que c'est pas mieux de partir de
ce principe la queue on s'en fout et
c'est magique mais voilà ce n'est pas
d'histoire live sur warhammer 40000 ça
peut le devenir a été voté non ce n'est
pas ce n'est bien rêve un live sur
minecraft sur le manque de programmes à
warhammer 40000 et je crois que oui par
défaut sur tweets je suis sur la
catégorie hammond est donc je pense que
cela est vide et dans la catégorie among
us way jusqu'à normalement tu peux
mettre un truc djatchi bien oui oui oui
mais comme j'ai pas bas comme je le fais
de fihri stream et que je n'ai je ne
sais pas si je vais directement sur ton
cul je ne sais pas si je peux changer ça
j'ai peur de tout casser en fait si
grave mais stable pour ce qu'il fait
n'est pas dû à mon gosse et il n'y aura
pas de bons gars ce soit à l'elysée on
avait conseillé à mon père
mais on entre tout ça est enfin là on
sera dans nos personnages
je suis nul je suis nul à ce jeu c'est
incroyable j'adorerais jouer mais je
suis nul incapable de mentir à ce très
bon les gens qui me tue dès le premier
tour et ça m'énerve c'est normal
dominique est à chaque fois tout de
suite bonne ligne elle est morte en
insultant là-bas salut les gars je vous
regarde et merci voilà est battu mais je
ne fais que nous verrons que suis
vraiment gaza on peut parler un peu de
la saison une avant de partir sur la
saison de f1
quel est votre meilleur souvenir qu'elle
est la fille du tournage de la scea
lentilles demande aux gens vous sur le
live et aux gens votre meilleur souvenir
du tournage de la saison moi dame a noté
guillaume et qu'après la wii je suis
désolé il du coup je vais raconter cette
histoire qui concerne plus de 48 ans
s'est passé dans ma cave s'est
littéralement vrai oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai ça commence bien entendu il faut
savoir que j'avais dans un immeuble de
co propriété la copropriété est très de
droite du coup je vais un peu dans le
stress que j'avais proposé de ma cave tu
vois je pensais pas qu'on soit j'irai
font ses pattes et viala donc on était
dans ma cave et j'avais j'avais commis
tous les dommages sur sur guillaume qui
devait être commis
finalement j'ai été ligotés bien d'une
année je suis avait maquillé un oeil au
beurre noir
incroyable d'une qualité folle et donc
je lui fais
je le ligotent mais choisit il faut que
ça se voit à l'image donc il n'est pas
juste mettre des cordes autour de ses
poignets tu vois c'est ridicule donc
j'ai fait un t4 shibari pour ceux qui ne
savent pas c'est un harnais qui passe au
niveau des épaules et ensuite sous la
poitrine et du coup c'est ça ce voit
mieux il faut savoir également que vous
avez un air là qui s'appelle le nerf
radial et qui passe et il faut pas le
compresser sinon quelqu'un qu'on
pressent votre nez radial comme des
hommes vous pouvez vous retrouver à
avoir mal au bras pendant deux mois
j'étais leader de quoi ah oui même même
presque plus mais ça vient mais ouais
mais qui ne l'a pas dire ça arrive et
genre en deux semaines après le tournage
je sais pas je verrai j'ai une petite
douleur au bras quand même puis ça a
duré comme dans quelques mois
et j'étais petit bout leur un peu sourde
ça allait mais changent pas que c'est
une boîte âge qui n'ont fait ça en fait
mais franchement il ya vraiment moyen
j'ai vu la façon dont tu
j'étais dégoûté kw à 4 heures et bien
longtemps car ben tu voulais revenir
tétons texte avant avant de jouer du
coup il y avait quitté page oui c'était
drôle ça 4 il ya une question oui il ya
une question tout à fait lors du premier
tournage vous aviez un timing assez
céreq
aurez-vous un timing plus facile pour
votre prochain tournage pour le premier
tournage c'est surtout on avait cinq
jours mais surtout c'était sur trois
week-ends 1 en juin et deux en août et
du coup là pour ce tournage
on va partir sur
une semaine intensive enfin intensive on
va essayer aussi d'avoir moins de plans
par jour parce que c'était vraiment
énorme pour pour la saison une on avait
je sais plus il y avait une journée avec
francky plan et c'était vraiment
beaucoup à 1,4940 oui je pense qu'on
voit très bon bah ouais je pense qu'il
faudrait même qu'on pense au multi dames
enfin tourner avec deux caméras comme ça
tu fais toute la scène en une fois et
même au niveau des relais des comédiens
c'est plus facile de tourner et citna
les deux personnages qui y vont à fond
dans tekken deux cadreurs pourra convoi
budget de plein de choses quoi mais du
coup on part sur a priori six jours le
journal donc une journée de plus
mais surtout on serait tous au même
endroit sur place et ça serait d'affilée
ce qui permet de rester beaucoup plus
dans l'ambiance et de d'être plus
efficace quoi et ses comptes compris
ouais rester concentré et tout ça et ça
serait tombé pas dépendre d'autres ouais
c'est ça donc le tournage c'est pas trés
dans le nord pour la saison une c'était
une partie dans le nord une partie
farhi et là on vient tous à tous
squatter chez ma mère qui est très
contente a mené à ce que pour maison
oui j'ai mis tu la connais et d'ailleurs
d'ici cet effet cette maison sera doté
d'une piscine parce que c'est bon c'est
bon j'ai hésité à venir mais vous avez
vu scénario ça veut dire un plan où elle
est de temps personne et deux dents mais
toi tu es au bord non et je pense que
lui crie sky dedans il me semble mais
mois coûte déjà bien du mal à finir pour
cet été mais oui c'est terrible parce
que j'ai lu le scénario je me rappelle
pas de ce plan et du coup quand tu me
dis que moi je suis au bord je ne sais
pas de qui tu parles à toi et toi
et ouais du coup donc j'aurai voilà on
serait basé plus que cette maison
servirait de lieu de tournage mais aussi
mais aussi d'autres endroits mais qu'ils
seraient tous à peu près autour on est à
peu près fixé sur tous les lieux cette
fois on pourrait bénéficier d'un café
fermé aussi puisque dans la saison et
non à tourner dans un café qui était
ouvert au moment où en tournée et ça
c'est papa le bar le bar de l'épisode iv
facile mais le petit café du village du
nord pas de calais 1 0
il ya déjà des clients parce que même si
on vient dimanche matin 11 heures il ya
beaucoup de monde dans ce petit café ça
c'était pas très grave il ya des gens
chez les experts ni signalés chaque
scène dans le nord mais exprimant draoui
diplômant thématique je pense que c'est
un bon investissement pour l'avenir
elle recourt je ne sont que cinq en or
pourquoi la dent d'avoir des piscines
c'est pas discrimination j'ai cliqué sur
wii ça fait de l'écho de ouf ouais mais
un petit peu d'écho bagdad 6 quand vous
ne parlait pas je sais pas si oui on
peut se douter
donc si jamais il ya dix ans mais où
elles elles le peuvent
dans le nord la à l'enfer à je me
souviens déjà de base on a oui je sais
plus si tu laisses pas signalé dans le
making of je suis pas quoi penser qu'ils
voient qu'on n'avait pas pu qu'on
n'avait pas plus de temps mais qu'on
n'avait pas pu tourner le jour où on
avait prévu de tourner parce que c'était
fermé sans qu'on nous prévienne oui sans
qu'on ne pas alors si on devait vraiment
tourner le samedi en plus il y avait
raffy du coup qu'il devait jouer oui à
la base je ne devais pas du tout
appareil mais du coup c'était raffy qui
devait faire la serveuse et qui n'était
là que le samedi donc elle vient exprès
hélas vrai mouvement d box fermé il ya
personne joram et y avait la petite
astuce permet quasiment va y avoir un
petit faux problème là parce que comment
on fait voilà donc j'ai dû me la peau
est venu pour rien leur parti que ce
soit parce qu'elles pouvaient pas rester
à pouvait pas rester deux jours pour de
suite donc qu on a improvisé et en plus
il y avait
on s'est dit on tourelles et le matin
dès 11 heures grand nocq ce soient les
aléas dimanche matin et elle m'a dit par
contre est déjà bien parce que bientôt
ça va être plein auourd'hui oui assez
aux yeux voici on arrive vers la fin les
gens ils vont peut-être pour manger
c'est donc on other n'y aura personne
vraiment c'était blain dax il y avait 10
p logo tel truc on gèle mais on va y
avoir un deuxième problème mais bon au
final c'est même ça c'est bon là on
s'est débrouillé et puis ça marche bien
doubler quand même oui ce que du coup
les fêtes dans le café dans l'épisode
c'est leur épisode 2 dans l'épisode 3 du
coup elles sont redoublé et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on a filmé bon comparaison
quand je parle cette fois qu'on filme
quand tu parles c'est moi qu'on filme
pour qu ils pas trop de redoublent âge à
faire non plus petit et ça il ya des
morts ce de début de phrase mais que
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué de tenir
la synchro sur une longue phrase est
heureusement du coup que la sienne et ip
parce que sinon on aurait été vraiment
dans la merde parce que là à la limite
ça fait la blague il ya cinq plans donc
on ne se rend pas trop compte qu'on ne
voit pas vraiment parler sur une scène
vraiment imagine et l'épisode avec
astrid dans le bar entier complètement
dans le nord est enfin je ne sais pas si
vous avez le merveilleux film 15 euros
on voit très bien que ça ne marche pas
le doublage
ouais ça fait la blague parce que c'est
ça mais où ça fait la blague ça va on se
dit pas je pense qu'au bout d'un an que
tu dis mais il ya un truc qui déconne je
pense si tu n'étais pas au courant et
que ça passe tellement vite
tu ne dis peut-être qu'il ya un truc qui
me un truc bizarre mais je pense qu'une
toute petite veste et rigolo mine de
rien à redoubler oui oui c'est bien ça
la postsynchro ouais mais n'hésitez pas
si vous avez des questions les questions
si vous voulez des méchants avec des
gueules je peux vous fournir dans tous
les cas on n'a pas encore casté tout le
monde quoi révéler qui va apparaître
mais il y aura des annonces pour
certains rôles il me semble à priori
rien à certains qui est juste qu'on n'a
pas dans notre entourage du coup on va
passer des annonces et donc n'hésitez
pas à candidater ça sera relayée sur la
page facebook la prof
voilà correspondait ou pas au rôle mais
voilà c'est possible le voilà vous êtes
tous des as du tout absolument pas je
donne des cours particuliers de temps en
temps sans que c'est volontaire
l'hormadi mahmoudi je me suis mieux
dominer du tout propre
ben voyons ok mais pourquoi faire a
battu l'as dit je te voyais quand je te
présente est hélas non tu ne dis pas que
tu prof
oui c'est moi qui décide alors mais le
fait d'être en vie dieu officiellement
je crois et sans betty plus ou moins
c'est là qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
d'autres comme anecdote comme souvenir
on était parti sur les bons souvenirs de
la saison une
en attendant n'hésitez pas si la pompe à
bière à quel enfer ça aussi mais
c'est à dire un comble justin dans le
marc de la saison quatre ou cinq ans je
te laisse pas ce que la saison 4 on n'y
est pas encore dans le barde d'épisodes
4 il y avait ce bruit de sitting pour
plaire aux textes et frigo on n'avait
pas trop suivi mais quand on tournait
dans la cave
donc pour ceux qui ont vu la série on va
on va un peu se polit la saison et là on
se parlera pas la saison 2 mais je fais
saison et d'un petit peu pour ceux qui
ont vu la série c'est quand aliénor et
lucrecia rencontre astree de la pirate
et oui il y avait beaucoup de bruit dans
cette cave qui n'était pas volontaire
alors déjà il y avait des pianos donc y
en a qui s'amusent à jouer au piano
parfois
le banc je travaille au lake de temps en
temps s'activer faisait du bruit
c'était le bar où je travaillais à paris
c'était où j'ai joué le barman dans dans
cet épisode là et j'étais littéralement
le barman dans la vraie vie aussi de ce
bar et j'avais réussi à accepter avec
ses managers puissent tourner une
journée dans la cave et c'est vrai que
par contre j'avais pas pensé au bruit
que faisait donc selon moi il ya tous
les fûts de bière qui est que ça fasse
autant de bruit puisque j'y suis assez
peu quand même
dans cette petite pièce mais je suis
vraiment désolé mais enfin c'est au
final tout s'est très bien passé il ya
eu des aléas de ne pas refermer les
bruits bah oui c'est qu'elles
s'éteignent et tout le temps oui sinon
mangue et salut salut mais parce qu'on
ne voulait pas la lumière de la cave on
avait mis nos spots mais des coûts de
santé à la cave la lumière il a les gens
ont allumé la lumière parce que quand tu
m'as les admire et la honte mais c'est
la cave
la forte chaleur et cécile étage ce qui
donne l'accès au parking à et ce n'est
pas bon non mais c'est moi j'écoutais
gare de templeuve en moi je connais
templeuve car je suis du nord mais
j'suis pas sûr que tout le monde conn
aître connaissent donc franchement je
suis désolé mais moi je connais même
probablement déjà ou est bizarre je m'en
fiche
moi je produis répandre callas tony
lewis hine par test reste encore du
domaine colonel gaye avec un mac 8
merci enfin si je me suis complètement
planté samedi oui ça partait stress quoi
au final une colonne belga les
britanniques ian gibson quelle taille
nostra grillades alentours c'est la
gaulette à la suite du début de la
guerre des gaules de césar effectivement
m'a fait apprendre 105e et je n'ai
jamais oublié d'ailleurs je t'ai bien qu
étant attendu justine exprime est un cas
pas pour ainsi d'aider l'europe est un
rempart pour la saison de prix j'ai vu
ça j'ai beaucoup rigolé ça va être très
sympa je pense que ça va être très sympa
ça et parce que pour parler un peu de la
saison 2 quand même un petit peu à venir
donc cette saison peut se passe dans la
continuité de la saison une déjà une
période indéterminée après la saison une
dépression longtemps après la saison il
s'est terminé comme vous le savez avec
certains personnages qui se retrouvaient
balancer o'connor précis ils ont une
éthique le pôle nord et donc peut-être
qu'on y répondra peut-être pas dans tous
les cas ce n'est pas ça n'est pas le
seul élément central de la saison de ça
sera pas une saison où les personnages
sont connor essaye de rentrer au début
de la saison
ce qu'on appelle budget d'abord parce
que ça serait peut-être pas si
intéressante
ils sont rentrés chez eux et puis bah
forcément il va se passer des choses et
des nouveaux personnages qui vont
apparaître et qui vont apporter des
complications de nouveaux méchants aussi
mais pas que et je me bats va pas bien
sur ce pôle et quels sont les enjeux de
la saison 2 mais ça tournera encore
autour de l'histoire enfin d'une
certaine forme d'histoires la saison une
ba
mon idée un peu un peu en sous-texte
s'étaient parlé de la mémoire que
rapports entre histoire et mémoire très
dans ce texte mais avec ces historiens
qui ont plus accès aux archives et qui
du coup bas vont puiser dans la mémoire
de leurs ancêtres pour réécrire
l'histoire
dans la saison 2 bon il ya aussi ce
rapport à la mémoire et puis aussi un
peu sur les conflits entre historiens et
l'autre quelque chose qui est un peu en
ce texte
zen l'heure un peu des infos là mais on
va peut-être parlé un petit peu des gens
qui veulent réécrire l'histoire est un
petit peu un petit peu du royalisme
aussi tu peux
un petit tabac et voilà mais oui je suis
bien amusé à les crimes et apparemment
c'est drôle ouais moi je me souviens
quand tu l'achète je l'avais déjà
commencé continent avait commencé le
tournage de gommage est à ce point
n'avait pas être terminée mais rien que
je suis envoyé et j'avais adoré que je
me souviens avec avec fred qui jouait
sur godefroy titien qu'on a qu'on a eu
tous les deux et qu'on va vraiment
essayer de faire une timeline des trucs
ça c'était on est et on était trop chaud
me des parts en direct et je suis très
content que ça se passe parce que
vraiment bas quand tu habites sur le but
je trouve que c'est
c'est tellement une autre dimension
c'est tellement notre ambition que je
ce serait ça serait dommage pas de faire
parce qu'on peut le faire et ils savent
être très bon non on n'espère c'est pour
ça aussi que le guide est un peu plus
conséquent parce que c'est une
donc déjà il ya plus six épisodes y en a
dix qui dure un peu plus longtemps aussi
et ben voilà on essaye aussi d'avoir une
équipe technique un peu plus fournie
comme le disent et l'eau pour pas avoir
un réalisateur chez fog cadreur monteur
voilà on essaye de pouvoir avoir un peu
plus de gens pour un peu plus de confort
et voilà c'est ça c'était stressant le
tournage de la saison une parce que bon
on t'a plu parce que tu as plusieurs
casquettes qui n'arrête jamais de penser
en fait moi moi j'étais plus dans la
partie pré production organisation tous
les documents écrits ça et puis sur le
tournage à la fois être devant un peu et
derrière la caméra parce que voilà
c'était stressant et donc on essaye
d'avoir un peu plus de monde pour
pouvoir un peu mieux délégué un peu
mieux répartir les rôles ce qui est la
raison pour laquelle le budget est un
peu plus conséquent voici et donc c'est
pour ça que oui on part sur cinq mille
euros c'est la base qui nous permettrait
de tourner la série alors que pour la
saison une on appelait les 3300 euros
pour pour le tournage tout ça donc on
espère que ça pourra se faire après il
ya aussi bien sûr l'ailé and co vide que
ça ne peut pas maîtriser
on part du principe que job et fin
juillet et bassora jusqu'au dernier
moment pour partir à la du poil et on
verra si ça peut se faire ou pas bien
sûr si le co lead est toujours trop là
il faudra reporter hélas mais le mondial
à frais en été bon en était normalement
il y avait peu de chances que non mais
que du coup ci ça refait comme l'année
dernière tu oses sont dehors donc du
coup normalement l'épidémie ça devrait
être un peu moins galère après vous
tient aussi le bail de la vaccination
mais ça m'a l'air un peu compliqué en ce
moment voilà mais oui normalement
enfin il ya moins en général même que ce
soit
cette maladie là où celle des autres en
général les gens tombent moins malades
en était donc bon ça devrait pas être
pire dans le monde
ouais ça doit le faire quand on sait
combien les gars su'l je suis allé dans
le futur mais je ne peux rien y avait
deux ans et depuis je regarde mon agent
ciel est mais tel qu'il est vraiment si
le podcast passion médiéviste et si on
connaît la chaîne estonie la chaîne
youtube estonie oui je connais les deux
passions mais dévisse et à des
interviews des gens qui parlent de leurs
thèses beaucoup en histoire médiévale et
hilton y parle d'histoire et il faut
très bien aussi donc que fait-on la
magie du montage pour terrasser je vais
pas compris non plus aurait écrit ta
question moines copistes on a rien à
rien compris malheureusement les choses
du coup si le tournage ne peut pas avoir
lieu le montage ne peut pas avoir mieux
non plus mais où est le lien ulule le
lien il est alors question depuis deux
semaines le bienvenu et sur la page
facebook la prof
il est sur twitter également il est sur
la vidéo de présentation de deux clics
est sorti hier et qui qui présente la
campagne est donc sinon c'est à moi que
saison 2 mais je ne sais pas si oui je
crois que je peux envoyer un message
hope et on va le mettre dans
on ne peut pas poster des messages vers
des chaînes si ça fonctionne ah oui ça
veut dire que apparemment oui j'ai mis
le message sur youtube et sur twitch du
lien et l'uil dans le stream n'a
apparemment sur facebook vous ne pouvez
pas l'avoir encore mais dans tous les
cas sinon si vous êtes sur facebook il
est sur la surface dure qu'il ait des
îles et sur la page facebook
la prof au niveau des acnés as on est à
5 euros des 1000 euros un jeu j'annonce
un peu un nouveau nom là on à 995 euros
à vous prendrez bien qu'on passe à 1000
ça serait aisé serait beau wink wink
c'est cool mais au niveau des
accessoires et costumes
ah oui on a des nouveaux c'est ça aussi
qui fait que le budget a augmenté c'est
que pour les costumes de la saison une
on avait beaucoup puisé dans ma
garde-robe d'anciennes cosplayeuses et
pour la saison 2 il ya des nouveaux
personnages donc qui nécessitent des
nouveaux costumes qu'on n'a pas
forcément donc on va devoir acheter ou
faire ou louer un peu des trois mais il
ya un budget costumes et accessoires
aussi qu'il ya des nouveaux accessoires
forcément doit peut-être de nouvelles
choses j'aimerais plus voir tous les
commentaires grâce à cette pop up qui a
paru le gpt la question du moine copiste
et 1 go eco et du coup lyon bat big boss
parce que ça on serait obligé
appartenant au second tour jean et va
mener de front avec t2c ont filmé de
manière personnes à chaque personnage ah
oui oui non puis ça veut dire qu'on n'a
pas de décors enfin parce que déjà en
plus on le fait déjà un peu puisqu'il ya
certains personnages alors on essaie de
l'éviter le plus possible mais comme
chaque acte un cap à tous les acteurs
mais plusieurs acteurs jour joue
plusieurs personnages il ya quelques
plans ou il se retrouve à 200 même plan
donc là on est obligé de filmer en deux
fois fin de l'est
c'est tourner la caméra bîmes l'acteur
se bat on va se changer et revient et on
filme la fin du plan la deuxième partie
quoi et donc ça c'est assez technique
faire ça sur toute une série c'est
contre j'avais pensé au tout début quand
j'avais écrit la saison une et que
j'avais encore contacté personne j'avais
juste écrite dans mon coin
au début je l'avais écrite pour jouer
tous mes ancêtres et non fossiles
humains du coup juste insuffisant
oui pour le coup c'est ce que j'ai fait
sur ma saison 3 de ma propre web série
de jouer tous les personnages tout seul
et c'est une horreur super complexe à
mettre en place à gérer en amont a géré
pendant et au niveau du montage c'est
très très compliqué c'est très très long
selon beaucoup d'énergie et je le
conseille
c'est amusant à faire tant qu'actrice
mais le reste non moi et puis cette
technique aussi enfin réussir direct à
switcher sur un autre personnage
enfin c'est quand on est talentueux
comme moi l espace n'est pas beaucoup de
difficultés mais je conviens que ce ne
soit pas évident pour la plupart des
gens quand je passe encore
je souhaite préciser une technicalité je
sais pas un mot je m'en fiche
par rapport à hull vous n'êtes pas
débuter avant la fin de la campagne qui
est dans 40 jours
voilà c'est une star c'est un paramètre
qu'il convient de rappeler vous serez
débités dans 40 jours si vous faites un
don est là aujourd'hui pas si la
campagne date un palais le premier
palier dans ce cas là on a donc le
donnez nous de l'argent
le premier palier 10 ans et 1 c'est un
minimum qui nous permettra tournée et je
l'avais dit dans l'autre vidéo et sur la
page de l'ul pour qu'on ait vraiment les
mêmes conditions que la saison une il
faudrait six mille euros
mais voilà je pense qu'à à 5000 on peut
enfin d'après les calculs tout ça on a
fait de budget à 5000 on peut déjà là tu
la tournée en se restreignant un peu et
du coup pour pour facile pour avoir un
peu plus de chance de la tournée c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis ce premier pas
à saint gilles donc ça aurait y arriver
et s'il vous même vous ne pouvez pas de
ce qui est aussi compréhensible en
seconde on est quand même dans une
période qui est pas forcément évidente
pour tous loin parlez-en autour de vous
en genre de truc c'est trop bien parce
qu'en plus imaginons vous arrive à
convaincre un pote est pas quand plate
série sera tournée et qu'elle sera
diffusée vous pourra en parler entre
vous faire vos propres théories vous
pourrez construire un peu une petite
communauté entre vous alors moi
s'écoulant times et vous verrez que vous
ne pouvez pas donner me semble partagée
il ya d'autres gens qui vont donner
place
je suis très en colère
non c'est ça le partage simple si on
parle de demande vous avez peur qu'on
remue la merde pour la saison une on
avait tourné avec un canon 550d pour la
saison 2 on sait pas encore soit parce
qu'on a un cadreur qui est pas encore
sûr de pouvoir être là soit on
tournerait avec sa caméra qui est mieux
soit on reprendrait la can avec
peut-être tout en louant quelques
objectifs mais mais mais justin tu sais
que j'ai un 60d tu vois soit on
utiliserait le canot de 60 des de
florence cassez est déjà capable par
rapport aux 650 des bien que pas
toujours pas idéal mais voilà sur tous
les objets d'exception pourtant mais
gégé
je suis plutôt équipés en objet bon mani
khel je suis embauché defacto oui mais
après dix mois au niveau éclairage par
contre on est pas mal à voir pas mal de
choses donc ça sert à quoi sert à se
débrouiller totalement et son masque
c'est un ingé son que nous trouverons et
qui on n'a pas du coup on n'a pas encore
l'ingestion par contre mais mon
programme
oui car c'est très important le son et
pour la saison une on avait un très beau
d'injection mais qui n'est pas
disponible
heureusement mes constats que nous
l'aimons
bah du coup j'ai calé j'ai deux trois
contacts en marge et songe que les
filets
bah oui mais c'est aussi très important
c'est un live pré prod en fait c'est ça
une réunion maintenant on a déjà fait on
a déjà fait des réunions et puis surtout
et on avait l'ingestion au début puis on
l'a plus donc ses récents mais on n'en
veut pas énormément de questions lui en
veux non c'est parce qu'il a eu l'idée
pourquoi je n'ai pas proposé à la
première réunion que j'avais des
contacts parce qu'on avait déjà à la
légère je me disais mais chez vraiment
une personne n'ose pas bien même mal
précis tu la joues la troupe elle l'a
fait elle s'en souvient pas aisée pour
sakineh à partir des médicaments
[Musique]
ce pack à qui tu dis comment à toi je
disais à vue pour n'a toujours pas les
fêtes les balançoires live ce serait un
petit peu la pression
oui dans n'a pas encore d'un geste on
l'a c'est un live sur plusieurs
ordinateurs dont que la qualité de ta
mort saison 2 sera meilleur que la
qualité de ce live ce soir plus à celle
ci ça c'est sa voiture et quelques uns à
2,70 euros
allez on va on va faire la police
m'ennuie quoi trop bien et oui qu'est ce
que je voudrais dire oui par contre on a
toujours notre compositeur qui revient
et qui avait fait des très bonnes
musiques et donc ça c'est cool aussi
c'est une très bonne affaire excellent
c'est vraiment bien oui vous devez faire
l'équipe ça faut aller voir le making
off parce que ça lui en parler c'est
super oui j'étais allé le filmer et
que j'ai mis à la fin du making-of son
interview il fait une démonstration de
comment et compose aussi et c'est
impressionnant j'imagine c'est génial
j'ai bien avec le son sourd santé oms la
connecter à son ordi plus d'autres
instruments 1 dans sa mouche 1 1
je sais plus intérêts les lames
inintérêt mid qui avec lequel donc on le
voit on voit vraiment bien dotée d'une
main on voit pierre heuzé d'une main à
faire arrêter la mise de côté et
souffler en même temps pour pour enfin
pour régler pour d'autres réglages c'est
vraiment impressionnant
c'est un bon voilà c'est un bon week-end
seront le salut et d'armes non mais ce
qu'est ce qui est fou en plus c'est pour
la saison 1 vraiment je me souviens
qu'on lui proposait des trucs
enfin vite fait et enfin a été ou sera t
elle pas il comprenait tout de suite ce
qu'on voulait lui dit enfin vraiment je
sais plus je sais pas plus dans les
détails mais il ya eu peut-être aller un
retour de retour grand max et si à
nicolet film musical donné par donc ça
il ya ka sat est vraiment la créativité
et l'inspiration douteux ou puis un but
un peu partout enfin je sais pas moi ta
main jamais eu l'idée en prenons le
train en revenant du french festival
d'avignon et d'un coup je m'étais dit ah
tiens je pourrais faire une une série
qui parlerait de des personnages qui
apparaissent dans mes temps mes
chroniques
eh bien oui il pourrait y avoir ces
enjeux là pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
apparaissent et voilà ça c'était un
petit c'est comme ça mais comme j'avais
dit au début j'avais écrit juste pour
moi et je savais pas du tout quoi en
faire et c'est après que j'ai n'est que
j'ai commencé à en parler à mes amis
puisque vous je vous connaissez tous
d'avant enfin sauf la toile du cou qui
apparaît pour la saison 2008 donc voilà
c'est en en parlant ensuite à des
contacts et puis les gens se sont
proposés pour dire moi je pourrais faire
ça je pourrais faire ça donc la saison
il s'était vraiment aussi entre potes
globalement c'était très sympa c'était
bien on a bien rigolé je me sens oui pas
d'avoir des potes chouette
des passeports indique où les super
valentin c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas cité
son nom c'est valentin jeune scène je
sais pas s'il a une page proulx quelque
chose peut-être qu'il a un site de
titres et d'ailleurs je me souviens plus
du tout faire capoter les quelque part
juste qui loupa nom final au final avec
la post prod qui est enfin ouais ça on a
mis du temps à envoyer les contreparties
et tout on a eu on a eu plusieurs galère
et complications et du coup non j'ai pas
poster les musées alors pas pour elle ça
pourrait bon truc pendant la campagne en
vrai après ces mesures mais c'est
vraiment la piste pour l'épisode et du
coup avec plusieurs thèmes fin c'est pas
vraiment des thèmes comme quand on
écoute une musique de film motta c'est
vraiment la musique qui vaquent épisodes
dont la cale et bim à diana après il ya
pas vraiment de thème de personnages
mais il ya des thèmes qui reviennent
pour le pour la cyber histoire il y
avait un thème aussi un peu il n'y a pas
un morceau du thème de tel perso mais
par exemple pour un gagnant il y avait
des tables giraud venez y avait pas d
instruments aussi un peu je suis plus je
sais là où ça fait longtemps que je sais
c'est désormais à privilégier selon les
perso je peux je ne sais plus bas
j'imagine qu'il avait une réflexion là
dessus parce que ouais ouais
après oui c'est des fois ça marche pas
mais ouanna et c'était vraiment cool
cilic
moi je dit rollin ouais c'est une super
de travailler avec lui en lui fais un
retour vous rejetez juste passait super
bien
soit on les a c'en est très gentil soit
il était très bon et je pense que c'est
ça après on est des personnes
exceptionnelles aussi enfin je veux dire
enfin je pense on peut jeter des fleurs
on est absolument incroyable
voilà si la dame en une blague
désamorce tout de suite contre auxerre
par contre bâle c'est très loin il ya
aussi des écoles de cinéma dans le nord
et je pense que si on devait recruter
technique et qu'on n'avait pas dans nos
contacts je pense qu'on serait plus sûr
des gens du nord quand même que des gens
d'aubaine mais merci pour l'info tout
gentil oui il a des problèmes de droits
du j'arrive jamais avoir le dernier mot
à cause d'une pop up je suis 3 du
travail oui en plus de base
enfin le fait de nous à la limite ça va
enfin on conçoit pas à payer qui épate
on montre à quoi que ce soit on est amis
bon limite voilà quoi mais c'est vrai
que faire venir des gens qu'on connaît
pas par le juge je ne suis pas à l'abri
du projet je parle un peu peut-être plus
que je me donnera mais en reste bénévole
même si on parle de parfois rémunération
sa race du défraiement parce que c'est
jamais on n'est jamais dans les tarifs
en vigueur jeudi d assez de pouvoir et
l'argent de poche on voit là et si on
arrive à filer un petit peu d'argent en
plus pour chaque personne qui s'investit
dans projet c'est tant mieux parce que
voilà c'est quand même un gros
investissement mais mais on n'atteindra
jamais un niveau de rémunération sinon
il faudrait beaucoup plus que c'est que
5 millions c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
reste dans une équipe un peu réduit fait
plutôt appel aux gens concours dit mais
après si vous voulez donner plus
d'argent nous on veut bien ça ne peut
aller un petit 38 euros la chaîne serait
chouette
comme ça allez moi sommes pas comme ça
on aura deux piscines et spas de payer
la piscine de ma mère elle si nous avons
forcé à pierre abélard genre d aboyer
exactement quelqu'un demande ce que tu
cries tu tricote je prends avec emi cdi
en coton mignon c'est la même chose et
elle peut être réversible sa live souris
et l'autre pour ravir la tête je viens
apprendre la colère qui fait des crises
en ce moment à lui montrer la kiffer les
colères alors on n'est pas content ou du
pas bien mais là on est content donc on
arrête maître-chien entente contente
parce que là il nous fait des crises
m'essayer on est bien apte à perdre
demain si on a fait beaucoup de repérage
et ça justement que j'ai fait des
repérages le week-end dernier
oui du coup bas il ya beaucoup de décors
que que j'avais assez vite en tête
on a perdu ce moment il ya beaucoup de
décors que j'avais assez vite en tête
validé comme je disais cette tournée
dans le nord donc j'ai cherché à partir
de là donc on va tourner un peu de chez
des gens que je connais des contacts
aussi qu'on avait via méconnaissance du
nord donc pour pour le café par exemple
est ce qui nous manquait c'était le
repère des méchants en gros et ça lui
donne des barrages le week end dernier
j'ai visité deux endroits
et justement on va en parler avec la
chef homme je pense qu'on part plutôt
sur un des endroits plus on a déjà on a
déjà regardé les photos et tout est
analysé et je pense que tu seras
d'accord avec nous mais non mais je
pense un autre
bordel fait en gros c'est sont devenus
si tu peux en parler
voyez pas les photos au tueur s
c'est un vitrail terme mais si on va en
parler parce que ça serait intéressant
parce que l'idée c'est d'avoir un peu d
entre courants car bâtiment tout ça il y
en a une armée gens sont très gentils
par contre est très disponible
mais c'est vrai que je pense qu'on
pourra pas vraiment caser les décors
parce que enfin ne pouvait pas vraiment
servir de beaucoup de pièces parce que
ben c'était fermé il ya plein de choses
dedans et on va pas leur demander de
tout déménager
ouais si comme en faut plus si jamais on
a des gens qui sont allergiques aux
pointes est le truc tout con mais ça
peut ni qui est un tournage en fait dans
l'autre
moi je le suis je ne le suis pas mais
voilà on sait jamais un mode quelqu'un
de l'équipe technique
tu vois ça peut ben ça peut être on
demandera les allergies alimentaires et
tout ça comme on avait fait il y avait
une petite fiche pour la saison une
après société où il se manière
informelle on avait demandé j'ai fait un
lapsus aller manger aussi quand on avait
bien manger d'ailleurs on retrouve notre
régisseur qui aurait dû être là ce soir
mais qui n'ont pas pu venir mais voilà
aussi pour la saison je sais ta bonne
nourriture
oui la librairie a d'ailleurs vous le
verrez dans une petite vidéo puisque
certains membres de l'équipe ont réalisé
des petites vidéos pour la promotion de
pas pour la campagne de financement et
j'ai sortirait au fur et à mesure de la
campagne dont vous verrez aussi le
régisseur qui dans la saison une était
notre passant plainte
le passant qui dit qu'il s'est pris un
peu plainte dans l'épisode 3 oui vous
votiez qui sait
c'est qui dit qui est le titre du light
n'est pas bon oui mais je commandais
depuis reste rim je peux pas vraiment
changé je pense que tu as essayé mais
peut-être que je vais tout casser
non je vais essayer raison en live
ah oui je peux aller aux gestionnaires
de stream si j'appuie longuement sur mon
avatar bien chaude
ah oui ça dit que g stream dieu mon gars
c'est que ça s'appelle retour de la
bastonnade
techniquement cela dit si c'est sa
mémoire je veux pas trop je connais mais
ça a été vraiment encore c'est pas un
gros son action avec des ralentis un
conseiller en combat de sabre qui fait
d'une s'accroît laser qui avait fait les
chorégraphies de combat sur mon court
métrage the north force et qui a dit
qu'il était partant pour pour feu donner
des conseils que tu es déjà seulement on
dit karaté voilà c'était intéressant sur
marbre voilà c'est bête soit avoir vu
pour avoir vu clemi se battre dans ce
projet qui n'a rien du jour elle se
débrouille des rabais
je sais la terrisse encore
écoute moi j'ai claqué sa à mai sortira
toujours cette vidéo peut-être je sais
pas comment parce que ça fait cinq ans
maintenant mais clemi on black widow
d'un gars c'était quelque chose
ouais ça va me dire enfin le sujet mais
on n'a pas parlé du fait que la veille
du tournage ami tu t'étais fait une
entorse et que tu étais aux urgences
jusque tard dans la nuit alors
directrice
le premier oui ça c'était pas là c'était
pas la veille du départ c'était le jour
du départ oui le jour du tournage de vos
qualités la veille au soir les passants
si vous êtes venu me chercher chez moi
pourquoi que j'ai à prendre le train
tout ça parce que j'avais mon appel
évadés qui est je passais la journée de
tournage sur le canapé heureusement
parce que les crises ya c'est une grosse
patate et c'était bien pour essayer de
modifier le titre du live je vous laisse
deux minutes ne fait d'ailleurs très
bien
tut tut tut par heure j'allais me
tromper de près non non qu'est ce que
fait non elle est partie ok très bien
quoi qu est ce qu a cédé place a évoqué
les toilettes perrine nous va commencer
comme ça une bande de potes qui tourne
n'aurais imaginé qu'il soit allé si loin
disant ah mais oui non mais même alors
je la série noob oui mais tu as même en
ce moment là
le film visiteur du futur qui est notre
série qui date d'il ya dix ans plus de
dix ans pareil et là ils sont en train
de tourner un film avec une prod est
probablement un film à plusieurs
millions d'euros tu vois passer oui j'ai
clairement peut-être que nous un jour ce
sera pareil du tout mais non il n'y a
pas eu de but oui restons positifs et la
loi de l'attraction tu brasses de marche
que si on dit que ça va marcher
donc il faut faire des trucs c'est clair
il faut faire des trucs j'ai réussi un
an mais à aller je suis vraiment content
quand les prochaines vidéos d'histoire
bah du coup j'ai un tout petit peu
retarder la prochaine vidéo d'histoire
qui est un jean todt i'm bad ass mais je
crois que j'ai programmé pour ce
mercredi où les mercredis suivants je
suis plus sûr du coup c'est un
randonneur c'est un jean todt i'm bad
ass et après bas j'alterne toujours
maintenant entre jean todt à m'agacer
chronique de preuves donc le mois
suivant ça sera un boni de profs et
nourriture des romains eh bien on mange
très bien
voilà moi j'en sais rien je devins gurgy
de seconde zone que mon routeur qui
pousse progressivement boiseau n'est pas
ce que c'est dommage de mourir comme ça
mais voilà du miel du gard du poivre
c'est délicieux
tout à fait en plus je me rappelle qu'en
5e il y avait des filles et faire un
exposé sur la nourriture de l'époque et
qui avait rien
et manger voilà de vieux mais c'était
bon coup de vieux
un mémoire sur le banc et du coup ils
avaient le même âge et surtout les
données des mois dans des enfants y
avait l'odeur on m'a dit oui alors
wikipédia et fayolle de bruits parasites
avec les meilleurs et c'est bon donc les
romains couleurs vert et des nobles avec
d'autres choses aussi manger pas le fn
n'est pas l'heure par pure avec du pipi
voilà il faut le dire disons en bas et
si vous posez la question couteau devant
avec de l'uriné
c'est très bon pour le système
immunitaire dépréciateur ne fait pas ça
c'est joli n'essayez pas ça chez vous et
non clairement on n'est pas prêt non non
non on na na na nana na na ne fait pas
cercle s'il vous plaît qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire d'autre sur la saison et se
rapprocher de la fin du live tout
doucement mais j'aimerais j'aimerais
tellement parlé mais ça va ce pain
l'espace public voit pas ce qui se passe
cette bombe déni de choses la syrie ce
fut une copine une amie
c'est important parce que l'amitié c'est
beau être un truc que j'aime beaucoup
aussi dans la saison 2 avait laissé le
développement de à tanger un doute
aliéna nancy 6e avec le fichu depuis 16
ans qu'elle a un développement assez
intéressant fincke et pas spécialement
drôle enfin si c'est drôle mais il ya
quand même un fond derrière et je trouve
que c'est vraiment intéressant
j'aurais évidemment je ne peux pas en
dire plus mais ça va plus loin que juste
à les bêtes et tout le monde c'est pas
un jeu c'est assez intéressant bon allez
développer je pense à me paiera aux gens
ça vous plaira et que du coup j'ai envie
de développer aussi le jour mais bon
alors que les hawks ne joue pas les
autres toujours belle s'en fout c'était
juste un oui c'était dans l'alabama
saison doit séverine quoi kiki qui se
faisaient d'arthur et cm mais futur quoi
là il a et je suis content que le
développement est très sympa aussi une
scène je pense qu'il va être très sympa
sur ça qui explique aussi un peu le
23ème siècle
voilà ce qui se passe à l'univers est
bien étoffé 1
vous en saurez plus est intéressant
excusez moi ça marche depuis le détruit
dans le chat du coup
oui non mais on a arrêté de lire je n'ai
pas encore dit n'est donc je ne tchate
ya une réponse parce qu'à l'époque elle
se passe on a dit je crois que c'est pas
à présent alternatif appel se passe
avant l'épidémie de kobe dans tous les
cas ça c'est sûr qu'après trop vite dans
la saison 2 mais justement way après la
saison on imagine au malawi il ya
quelques jours non une règle quelque
chose à la fin un truc comme ça que j'ai
rajouté forcément ah mais oui mais mais
ces sétois en fait
guillaume et ses griots moment déjà du
coup je vais le redire ma scène préférée
de la saison de ses scénarios
voilà tu me l'avais dit je marque ou y
mais je sais pas oui oui aller j'avais
compris se joint à sa chute il ya alors
dans l'axé joueront les moments préférés
étaient aussi à la gueule puisque je
pouvais le torturait voir où elle en a
longtemps cabba et en lui tapant dessus
autant que la pirate donc vraiment on a
atteint le sommet énorme ambiance un peu
ligoté bien d'autres personnages qui
seront un peu un peu attaché un peu
torturé mais pas toi moi je les lâche
plus et c'est fini donc on y tourne par
un porno s'il vous plaît donc ya pas de
scènes de stade
rotimi un nom à ce camp mais là dessus
ça sur youtube personnages will failla
sous-texte éventuellement peut ignorer
sa votre phrase on veut n'y a pas un
jour mais de même pas où deux de ses
plus sûrs sur la famille oui c'est ça il
prend de faire les amis oui c'est
important pouvoir de l'amitié c'est bien
mais l'amitié
diack ça va être un peu bizarre de faire
des relations sexuelles entre l'ancêtre
à partir dans des trucs
il ya des tentatives le script parce que
j'ai pas tout retenu la réal nous avons
un personnage qui n'est pas vraiment
courant de sa position dans l'arbre
généalogique et qui essayent de draguer
un autre personnage qui n'est pas
intéressé
voilà je n'en dis pas plus pour donner
des saints comme ça vous aurez à vous de
votre passé retrouvé mais moi j'avais
droit à votre froid et s'y retrouver à
venise vous pouvez faire un spin off
[Musique]
j'ai un peu là ça sera un gros budget
comme m oui non mais ça c'est pas une
réponse par contre j'ai déjà la saison 3
en tête
j'ai la saison 3 et la saison 4 beaucoup
dac mais la saison 3 et prague l electro
love moi je trouve je veux trop savoir
de tout savoir justine dubois tous ont
fait maintenant on fait les ont fait le
campagne campagne saison 3 m'a surtout
fait le way nathan rées à novara volant
tout cas oui
donc ça veut dire que je ne pars pas
dans la saison que j'ai cassé les dents
le temps et maya son double du coût qui
la famille oui du coup c'est génial
parce que si un personnage meurt il peut
quand même revenir grâce au double oui
mais des fois il s'est accélérée mais
c'est pas grave ça veut dire que tu
perds pas ton emploi de comédien sur la
série le centre aquatique
une question a une vraie question
oui je vois ça vous comptez développer
l'univers sur d'autres supports que
youtube pour l'instant non déjà réussir
sinon ça peut être très sympa mais pour
l'instant on va déjà essayer je pense
que ben moi déjà je vais dire et des
bandes dessinées sur sur les trucs que
tu peux pas faire genre les passé des
personnages à part les persos genre lui
chrétiens à l'époque
de l'époque où elle était ça pourrait
même après c'est les petits spin-off tu
sais de fin des petits trucs en interne
mais ça quand je fais une petite série
voilà on est content des retours de la
saison nul n'en est pas non plus sur un
énorme truc déjà réussi à réaliser à
saison de ça sera bien donc je le
rappelle est très ambitieuse et du bâti
oui oui y'a pas sa préférée avec avec du
béton
le temps passa ouais il ya ya ya ya la
scène incroyable acquéri est vraiment
croyez moi il faut financer ça on l'a
déjà répété une première fois pour voir
le flou mais nos répétitions pas en
visio et c'est particulièrement drôle
quand deux personnages sont amenés à
disputer ensemble alors qu'ils sont
joués par la même personne
imaginez ce que c'est tellement beau le
prêt bizarre de fêter t'es pas là je
crois que c'est que les comédiens mais
ce n'est pas noël the take away
mais oui c'était très drôle j'aurai la
surprise
je veux donner le meilleur
un nouveau personnage de clinique et
aussi des dialogues est assez assez
travaillé du tout ça ça rendait bien
aussi attends je t'adore ce personnage
ouais c'est le premier phare le soin le
savait non mais du coup ses jours
[Musique]
un récit toi qui fais le mieux ressortir
la lapine est finalement nature et syrie
je sais je sais plus exactement qui joue
qu'il y ait enfin comme je sais que vous
rejouer enfin plusieurs persos métriques
en tête qui jouait perso
mais la côte d'ivoire parce que je pense
que tu as dirigé par le jeu et on peut
et on termine que les vies parce que
c'est bizarre demba tard robben mais je
vais prendre ça comme un compliment
parce que sinon je voudrais prendre du
lexomil ses personnages préférés
[Musique]
il ya un autre nouveau personnage
masculin que jamais bien aussi et qui
sera mais ça va trop bien ça va être
problème sinon je crois tu vraiment je
suis je suis je ne sais pas pourquoi je
suis autant que c est parce qu on est
confiné le pire non et qu'on a envie de
sortir de voir des gens et d'avoir des
d'interaction six mois en fait oui et
j'ai oublié dire aussi que on retrouve
pour le graphisme
parce que si elle est déjà sur la page
de lui l'on n'a rafiki affaires bel
arbre généalogique sur la page du loup
et donc n'hésitez pas à les voir qui
peut vous permettre de vous y retrouver
un petit peu mieux aussi
et pour l'instant vous pouvez voir qu'il
a des trous parce que pas forcément il
ya des personnages qui ça peut vous
indiquer un peu la période où se situent
les persuader nouveaux personnages selon
où se trouvent des trous dans l'arbre si
vous avez des notions d'histoire
d'à-peu-près niveau 6
[Musique]
donc pour les plus jeunes désolé ça se
serait approché voilà oui c'est ça mais
oui du coup elle fait du très bon
travail et puis elle avait déjà fait les
miniatures des graphismes de la saison
une
et puis et puis et bah du coup elle
avait un tout petit rôle aussi dans la
saison et les posteurs de personnages et
de posters de personnages oui voilà
c'est quelqu'un de bien et les badges et
aussi le visuel du dvd pour ceux qui
avaient la contrepartie dvd celle qui
avait fait le visuel de du boîtier au
titre du dvd quoi les éléments pour
l'autre carton du pour le dans les dents
là dans la vidéo les le titre du film et
tous les textures celle qu avec c'est au
sénat j'avais trouvé une police de
titres qui me plaisait et puis à partir
de là elle a développé avec les petits
engrenage tout ça elle les a modifié on
a travaillé madérien est bien trop il ya
une question sur la viande oeufs genre
dans temps de manger que rarement de la
viande
oui c'est un cliché après ça dépend des
forcément quand même du niveau de
richesse
et puis c'est pas la même forme de
viande les régions manger un peu plus de
la viande fraîche sinon ça va être plus
de la viande séchée par exemple parce
que ça conserve mieux voilà mais j'ai
fait une vidéo sur l'alimentation au
moyen-âge dupont va pas partir sur
l'histoire ici mais j'en parle et dans
mon livre aussi est dans ton livre livre
j'ai écrit un livre aussi c'est pour ça
que j'étais pas mal occupé qu'à saison
de votants à sortir mais j'ai écrit un
livre sur la vie quotidienne au
moyen-âge et il ya un chapitre sur
l'alimentation qui peut-être que je suis
à nouveau en train d'écrire d'ailleurs
fait une coop avec simon depuis hier et
en vrai trop bonne idée je suis
monté hier pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas c'est un buteur qui fait rester
il fait des posters de films mais avec
le style des enluminures de moyen-âge et
tous avec c'est hilarant c'est vraiment
très drôle si vous avez l'occasion de
jeter un coup d'oeil là un coup d'oeil
et c'est vraiment et voilà un coup
d'oeil sur les failles et marcoux y est
oui oui j'ai mes règles à trop d'infos
suis un seul sinon de tuilières aussi
voilà d'ailleurs que son dauphin pierre
léaud de quelqu'un de connu dans la
saison 2 mais ça on va pas bien c'est
comique non non non pas tant
et j'ai des followers sur tik tok hockey
et de toute façon ce serait par un
calvaire puisque tu toujours plusieurs
des rôles principaux
tout à fait donnez lui bien que qui est
un bon point et que tu ne joues pas toi
même tu joues des personnages
et oui pourquoi on ne ferait pas un
caméo de khemis nos fait du coup
d'accord d'accord
[Musique]
ouais c'est pas possible ça on peut pas
accepter ça on peut accepter que les
descendantes eu des ancêtres mais que tu
apparaissent dans la série en tant que
toi annoncé c'est vraiment impossible
steele eagle elle a bossé sont chacun a
ses limites
bon je sais pas ce que vous en dites je
pense qu'on va peut-être pouvoir arriver
à la conclusion de ce live mais parce
qu'on a faim sachant qu'on a donné
l'idée d'en faire deux autres un vers le
milieu de la campagne et un vers la fin
de la campagne et pour celui du milieu
j'avais envie qu'on fasse des quizz et
des trucs et des jeux qu'il faut
réinventer mais est ce qu'on apprend
tous les jours avec keep up with fait
mais tu pourras nous inventer des jeux
non sachez que je sais faire ça dans
l'histoire sur des voyages l'entente une
croix sur la saison une on peut partir
votre famille et tous ses amis sûrs que
les dix mots voilà ça c'est bien enfin
un penny mais non mais quelle est la
vraie couleur des cheveux libres non lui
d' n'est pas des idées oui tu as perdu
un peu oui t'as vu j'ai essayé un
problème de gossip de tondeuse voilà
mais non ça ne pas bien hâte de voir
cette saison deux en tout cas pas nous
aussi on a hâte de la voir
et pour cela n'hésitez de la sphère de
jean pagé la page
et si vous pouvez si vous le voulez a
donné des sous oui je parlez-en autour
de vous s'il vous plaît mais c'est super
soyez enthousiaste comme je le suis et
comme on l'est tous est l'homme le plus
ancien statut live débit normal je suis
content de chaco est en fait je me suis
rappelé 38 arrêts mais toute cette
semaine parce que parce que parce que
parce qu'à condom
non mais alors qu'en plus ce nom
godefroy donc du coup non françois il
physiquement il a de la barbe et où il
ya des poils sur le visage pour le sens
attend qu'un petit personnel une petite
fée du mat façon déjà dans la saison
hamilton aux figurants quasi c'était des
gens de l'équipe tech 1 10 de françois
le son très bon voilà on se lave les ac
il ya des débats sur le nucléaire et les
fours il est acquis mais après la saison
de weeds ne fais pas ton timide zac est
des nôtres
je suis en live il faut pas que tu me
parles
merci pour vos questions et merci pour
votre bonne humeur dans le tchat
oui mais voilà bois sauf si vous avez
des choses à rajouter
est-ce que vous avez d'autres questions
le live d'ailleurs le chat
bonjour françois on n'avait pas vu la
skip dans l'alphabet la présentation de
joie il suffit de poser à we dance à
nouveau la discussion sur les poulets
nucléaire la phase de poules et les
relancer le four
oui c'est le père est ce qu'un jour et
aux liens non attention il ne faut pas
pousser
mais en tout cas sachez que ce fut un
plaisir
oui c'était vraiment très très enfin oui
j'espère on a bien rigolé brophey saint
bernard où on vous fait des bisous j'ai
fait un le laisse on veut posterez un
petit truc sur facebook et sur twitter
qui rappellera la campagne mais aussi
qui apportera des éléments s'apprête se
voit une redite de la saison une les
bêtisiers des kings qui vont
réapparaître et aussi des nouvelles
choses notamment mal et des vidéos de
promo de la par exemple ont acclamé et
florence qui ont réalisé et qui du coup
seront diffusées et et autres choses du
coup ben vers le milieu de la campagne
message aux en reparlerai il y aura un
nouveau live et enfin la campagne aura
dernier live ce direct ça permet de ne
pas se dire est que ce appareil de time
warp donner d'espoir timemark voilà ça
vous met un accent dit rudge moi je dis
qu'il faut goûter avec soin non mais au
nombre de décès de nous aider à bien
finir le live qu'avec mes codes je
n'arrive pas à savoir ce que je n'avais
pas les codes et donc c'est quelqu'un
sympathique
oui
merci à donner de l'argent à l'identique
d'ailleurs on a passé le seuil des
débiles donc oui super cool on a déjà du
coup tu prenais pas lui ai donc c'est
cool et puis merci au chat merci à tous
oui merci beaucoup aux gens qui veulent
rester parce que le chiffre est resté
constant donc c'est que ça vous a
intéressé
oui merci m à bientôt mais et continuer
de parler de paille de continuer or
voilà